The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
JOHN W. ROBERTS:
Our investigation
of stochastic gradient descent.
This time, we'll be talking
about the stochastic policy
interpretation.
And I have some examples.
Well, a very simple
sort of system example.
But a whole bunch of ways of
looking and fooling with it
in policy parameters that
hopefully give you some
feel for how to actually
go about using this,
if you want to use in your
project or something like that.
So here.
OK.
So I gave a little
introduction to the idea
of a stochastic
policy last time.
But this time, I'll give maybe
a little review of the things
and also a sketch
of the algorithm.
I think someone asked,
Joe asked for pseudocode.
To get a feel of the process
you need to go through.
So just in sort of words,
this is the process.
I'll just get right into it.
Set.
Alpha.
And again, there's
a bunch of ways
of actually implementing
this and going
through the details of it.
But this is a very simple
way and easy understand.
And most of the other
forms are pretty clearly
derived from this.
We can sort of tweak it
maybe to get a little bit
better performance or fill in
the details in different ways.
But set alpha to
an initial guess.
Wow.
Sorry.
So this is what you
start your policy off as.
You can start it as zero or
a bunch of random numbers.
And this can affect your
results a lot actually.
Good initial guesses will
obviously converge faster.
But also they can be a bit
different base of of attraction
for different local minima.
So it also makes sense sometimes
to run it several times
from different initial guesses
and just see where it goes.
And if they all converge
to the same thing,
that means you're at least
in a local minima that
has a large base of attraction.
While, if they are go to
very different things,
that means that you sort of
have a local minima problem.
And you can take the
minimum of all those runs
or you can try to
investigate exactly why you
keep on getting stuck.
So the initial guess
isn't just like come up
with the best thing you can.
It also means sort of map out
the space of policy parameters
somewhat so that, when you
get stuck in a local minima,
you have some confidence about
how good that policy really is.
So then this is again,
you don't have to do this.
But run a policy pi alpha.
So this is the policy with your
parameter set of your alpha.
And store the cost
as your baseline.
So that gives you
your first baseline.
Then let's see.
The Do While loop here.
So do draw noise z.
So if you remember before, maybe
I should sketch this first one
and fill both these
boards with the sketch,
z is the noise you
add to your policy.
So when you're searching,
when you sample,
that's the vector you add.
I'll write out the
details of it over there.
So draw your noise z
from some distribution.
Now, yesterday we talked about
the example of a Gaussian.
That's a common one.
But there's a number
of other ways.
And actually, today we'll talk
about a different distribution
and sort of why
you'd want to use it.
Run system with pi alpha plus z.
So this is sort of
when we're evaluating
how well that policy does.
And then we'll say we'll store
this just in J. All right.
Now, we do the update.
Remember?
That we were talking about.
So alpha gets alpha plus
negative eta J minus b.
b is our baseline up here.
So J minus b z.
And then update your baseline.
Now you can do this
with a second run
where you run your new policy.
That's sort of the
more expensive way.
But you can have confidence
in that baseline,
as long as it's not too random
when you evaluate the system.
You could do a decaying average.
You could have,
for example, b gets
0.2 times your J plus 0.8
times your old baseline.
Right?
And so, this one is sort of an
exponentially decaying average
where I take my new
one, smooth it out
by averaging with
the previous one.
And then if you think
about what this does,
sort of every
measurement gets sort
of exponentially decayed
away and its significance
as you go through time.
That's the update.
And then you can do this
while not converged.
So many times, you can
just do a four loop, too.
And you can just run
it for 100 iterations
or several iterations
and see whether or not
it looks to have converged.
That's what I often do.
But this is really what
I guess you're doing.
It's just the four looping
stuff is sometimes easier
and prevents you
from getting stuck
where your convergence
conditions ever met and you
have to Control C.
So hopefully this
is clear enough that, if you
wanted to implement this,
you can go do it and
try for your project
if that's what
you interested in.
All right.
So--
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE].
JOHN W. ROBERTS: I'm sorry.
This is et cetera.
There's different ways you
could update your baseline.
You could do it with a-- yeah.
Sorry.
I mean, these are
two common ones.
I mean, these are the
two that I usually use.
But you could have critics
and stuff like that, too,
where you have more
complicated updates for having
more complicated baseline.
All right.
So when should you use this?
We'll just say stochastic
gradient descent.
Well, it's important
to remember, one,
that it never does better
than true gradient descent.
So if it's cheap to
evaluate the true gradient,
you can follow that
true gradient down.
And you're in pretty good shape.
Now the fact that
it's random maybe
gives you some robustness
to very tiny local minima.
But you could add that
in your gradient descent,
too, if you're just [INAUDIBLE]
yourself around a bit.
So stochastic gradient descent,
if you have an easy way
to compute the gradients,
you can do gradient descent
using those.
Or you can even do something
like SNOPT or some high order
method.
So if it's easy to compute
the gradients, exactly.
It doesn't
necessarily make sense
to do stochastic
gradient descent.
If those gradients are
impossible to compute
or extremely
expensive to compute,
then it can make sense.
Then also, if you have
a good parameterization,
it can be quite efficient.
Again, I guess this isn't
a prerequisite because it
will work with high dimensions.
And just sort of like in
naive parameterizations.
Wow.
You just leave params.
But it'll be really slow.
But is slow.
And it can get stuck
in local minima.
So if you have a good
parameterization,
it can be much more
reasonable to use this.
An example is, in our
lab, we have this glider
we're trying to have perch.
So we launch it
out this catapult.
It flies through,
executes a maneuver,
and then tries to
catch this line.
Right?
Now, in that case, if
your parameterization
were the kind of
open loop tapes we've
previously used, where just
what elevator angle did
you try to serve
it to, that could
be a bad parameterization.
It's a course that's going to
demand sort of rough things.
And so, trying to do learning
on that can be very slow.
Especially because
evaluation is so expensive.
So if we can come up with a
good parameterization though,
suddenly it becomes
reasonable to do this.
If we can knock down to five
parameters that parameterize
a very sort of nice
class of policies,
now maybe we don't
need that much data.
And we can actually get
it just by launching it.
So if we can come up with a good
parameterization, doing this
should work.
Yeah?
STUDENT: What if you had
a good estimate of what
your trajectory should be?
Do you parameterize [INAUDIBLE]?
JOHN W. ROBERTS:
Well, I mean, you
could start with a
good initial guess,
which maybe means that you
converge reasonably quickly.
But the thing is
that the learning
is going to struggle to
get a lot of improvement.
It will get some improvement.
It'll show in these examples
you have ugly parameterizations,
it'll still learn a bit.
But the problem is that, if you
parameters in this open loop
tape, let's say we have some
really nice smooth trajectory
like this.
And we parameterize it.
Is this all clear?
Is this is sort of
off on a tangent?
But this is just sort of
about bad parameterizations.
So do you want me to go
through all this first?
And I can talk about
the points in detail?
STUDENT: Do you
need a microphone?
JOHN W. ROBERTS: I believe
I have a microphone.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
Thank you.
All right.
So are we all on board here?
Or are we-- yeah.
OK.
Good.
Yeah.
This is sort of disorganized.
So if you parameterize by
setting all these numbers,
you have a nice
smooth trajectory.
That's the kind
of stuff you want.
Now if you
parameterize by saying
each one of these numbers,
stochastic gradient descent
when it bounces around
is going to be like, OK.
Send this guy up a bit.
Send this guy down a bit.
These two guys up.
This guy down, this guy down.
Up.
This guy back in the same place.
You know?
Something like that.
And you get some param
policy like this.
Right?
Now your physical system is
going to smooth that out.
It's going to filter it.
Right?
You're not going to
execute something
like that necessarily.
But it's very
unlikely that that's
the right kind of policy.
Right?
I mean, it's very sort of
fine-grained tick-tick-tick
doesn't really make sense.
So if you assume you are going
to have something smooth,
it's nice to do something that's
going to be sort of always
relatively smooth.
If you were to use fewer
points parameters as a spline,
that could be a win.
So that's what I mean by a good
parameterization is something
that ideally captures
the kind of behaviors
you want in your system.
So yeah.
I think the main
point is don't--
well, this is not
the main point.
This is a big point that I think
a lot of people tend to do,
and I can be guilty
of myself, is
don't discard Back prop
through time, RTRL with SNOPT.
Many times, because you can
see how simple this update is,
it's very tempting
just to be like,
OK, well, I'll put
this loop and run it.
And I'll be in good shape.
I mean, because it's
trivial to write that code.
I mean, you can see it
from pseudocode here.
So when you're working
on your project,
if you're like oh well,
I want to optimize.
I'll just throw this on there.
Bam.
I mean, it'll take you 30
minutes to get that code ready.
But maybe you think back prop
through time is more confusing,
you have to do with all these
joint equations and stuff
like that.
But these give you
the true gradient.
If your gradients are cheap,
doing this can be a win.
And then you can
get a better policy.
You can solve it a lot faster.
You can check richer
classes of parameterizations
because it will solve
them so quickly.
So when you're thinking
about, OK, we're
trying to solve this problem
and you have your project,
don't choose this without
being very conscious that it
has a lot of limitations.
And there's a lot
of alternatives
which could be better.
So first think, are
there very solid
sort of things you
can do with these
using SNOPT converged nicely?
If you can't, if you don't have
a good model, if your system is
too complicated,
stochastic range descent
maybe is what you want.
All right.
So that's sort of a discussion
coming back from Tuesday
on when to do these things and
also hopefully code that now
that you have it in your notes.
Now that you have
it in your notes,
you'll be able to implement
this pretty easily.
So now getting onto
new stuff for today,
we're talking about
stochastic policies.
And in particular, we are
talking about a certain class
of these kind of algorithms.
Reinforced algorithms.
All right.
And I think that these were
introduced by Williams.
He's at Northeastern
in '92 or something.
So once again, trying
to get across the idea
of the stochastic policy.
So this interpretation
is very different.
We're not going
to linearization.
We're not going to assume
we have this nominal policy,
we sample and try
something else.
We're going to
assume that we have
some distribution of policy.
Our policy is a distribution.
So we can think about it as, we
parameterize our distribution
with alpha.
Our policy then has some
stochasticity to it,
which is going to give us what
used to be our alpha plus z.
Right?
So we know that this
is not a sample.
This is the output
of our policy.
This is how we
represent our policy.
Not as the nominal action,
but as some parameterization
of the behavior.
Right.
So this would be,
for example, if I
were to play a game where
I was flipping a coin
and I bet on something,
it could be like, OK.
My parameter here
is the percentage
of times I'm going to
bet money on it coming up
heads or something like that.
I mean, that doesn't
make sense because you're
[INAUDIBLE] is zero or net zero
if you're playing a fair game.
But the point is
that it's something
like, this is the
probability of doing this.
And so here, we're
going to think
about this as the mean
of a bunch of Gaussians.
So our policy is do
all these actions
with the probabilities described
by a multivariate Gaussian
with means described
by this vector.
All right.
OK.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
STUDENT: So you just
have alpha plus z,
is the policy just to add
noise to your parameters?
JOHN W. ROBERTS: I
mean, these are the two
different interpretations.
Right?
So I mean, it is
effectively doing that.
I mean over here, we
have our nominal thing.
And then we add this noise.
Right?
Then we have our nominal policy.
We add noise with
distribution like this.
But this one, what
we can have is this
is parameterizing
a distribution.
And our policy is to do these
things with this probability.
Right?
STUDENT: And you said
that alpha is the mean--
JOHN W. ROBERTS: For us, it's
the mean of these Gaussians.
But you could parameterize
it any way you wanted.
I mean, you could have a
policy parameterized by,
if you have discrete
actions, it could
be the probability
of all these actions
and force them to sum up to one.
It could be some
parameterization of a PDF
or something like that.
So we're going to talk
about it in a limited case.
And I think that thinking about
that way, at least for me,
is easier to think
about where we're going.
But remember, that's
a lot more general.
This is just parameterizing
some distribution of actions.
And so, it could be
something very general.
But if you're having trouble
putting your head around what
all that means, you can
think about it as just like,
this is describing the means
of a bunch of Gaussians.
And then our policy
is do these actions
with the probabilities
described by that.
Does that make sense?
I think that this is
sort of, I feel like I'm
running around in circles here.
All right.
I just want to be clear.
So in that case, it
doesn't make sense to say,
so this goes through our
system and produces cost J.
But now J is a random variable.
All right.
So it no longer makes sense to
say, what is J for this policy?
Because running
that policy is going
to produce all sorts
of different Js.
Right?
So when you evaluate
the policy, I
mean you could have a question
of, what is the right way?
Should you do the min of J?
Should you do, what is the
worst J it's going to produce?
Or what is the maximum
J it's going to produce?
Well, the thing that
we generally choose
in this world--
well, not Earth,
but our discipline--
is you want to look at
the expected value of J.
And so, this is a philosophical
decision to some degree.
I think Russ may have
talked about this a bit.
But when you're an
airliner, you probably
want to look at the min of J.
When you're building a gambling
robot, maybe you do want
the expected value of J.
So we have a lot of money.
Right?
And so, this is a
philosophical decision.
But it's analytically tractable.
And it makes sense
in many cases.
And again, like
Russ says, animals
aren't doing robust control.
I mean, if they were, we
wouldn't be sprinting around
and jumping, doing gymnastics.
Well, some people would
be doing gymnastics.
I'm probably not
doing them anyway.
But my expected value of
trying to do gymnastics
would not be high.
I can guarantee that much.
All right.
So what we're going to look
at is our stochastic gradient
set now.
Since we can't just
dJ d alpha, we're
going to have to look at d
expected value of J d alpha.
Right?
So this is now our metric.
And so we have to
look at the gradient
of that expected value.
Now, this then is the
definition of expected value.
Right?
We can call, I'm going to call
this sort of like the policy
parameters that you're
running on under this trial.
I'm going to call it
beta in an attempt
to be as unoriginal as possible.
So we're going to
call this beta.
So the expected
value for J we want
to integrate over all beta.
And your expected
value is going to be--
I'm sorry.
I've got an error in my notes.
So J of beta,
probability of beta.
So this is just definition
of expected value.
Now, if you push the
d, d alpha through--
yeah, sorry.
If you push the
d, d alpha through
for a beta, what you're going
to find is that J of beta
is not a function of alpha.
We're saying beta
up here written up
here is a function of alpha.
I mean, that's how
we've derived it.
But remember that beta is
just the actions you've
chosen from a distribution.
So if you look at running your
system with these parameters,
that's not a random variable.
That is just your number.
Right?
So the thing that varies
though is the probability
of getting beta.
Right?
This is the function,
this distribution.
So this is what
depends on alpha.
All right.
Now, this is where a bit
of cleverness comes in.
You can write this then as a
handle over beta, J beta P.
So you get the
distribution beta.
Then d, d alpha of
ln of p of beta.
d beta.
Right?
So this is just
saying, when you take
the derivative of
your natural log,
you're going to
cancel out this one.
Right?
You'll get the derivative
of the one inside.
That makes sense?
When you do a
chain rule on this,
you're going to get one over
P beta d P beta, d alpha.
So this is sort of the
trick that you need.
So you should see this.
All right.
I can erase the pseudocode.
So once you do that, if you look
at the expression over there,
what you can see is that it's
the same as the expected value
of J beta d ln P beta d alpha.
Right?
Because we're
integrating overall beta,
probability of beta.
Right?
So what's the expected
value of this?
That means that, if we can make
this our update, if we can make
effectively this our update,
then the expected value
of our update is equal
to the derivative
of the expected value of
our performance with respect
to our policy parameterization.
Do you see?
That's sort of cool.
Because this seems like
sort of a complicated thing,
the derivative of your
expected value with respect
to your policies, other things.
It's this big random thing
over a very complicated J.
Like a general J. We haven't
assumed anything about J.
We didn't do a linearization.
We didn't do anything like that.
Right?
So J is still however
general you want it to be.
It's not local anything.
The derivative this with respect
alpha, we can make this update.
We follow that derivative.
So that's pretty cool.
Right?
So the question is, now
what does this update
look like in practice?
This is kind of an ugly term.
So what happens when we actually
try to do an update like this?
Well, we can write
this as our update
in the direction
of the gradient is
going to be delta alpha again.
Now we want a learning rate
because this is again sort
of a gradient following thing.
So generally, in there, you
want some sort of learning rate.
And you're just going to
do a gradient descent.
You get this J of
beta, which again now
we can write this
is alpha plus z.
All right.
And then something to represent
that d ln d alpha P beta.
So we'll call that E. And
that's called the eligibility.
I think that term may
come from neural networks.
But you can think of it as
this eligibility captures
how sensitive each parameter
should be to an update.
So let's say we have 10 alphas.
And the eligibility for one
of those alphas is very high.
That means that, if we do
well, that eligibility should
go much more in that direction.
The eligibility is
sort of just capturing
the weights of
how much you think
each parameter is responsible
for affecting that output.
Right?
So a big eligibility
on a parameter
means that that parameter
is going to move a lot.
If the eligibility
is small, it's
not going to move much at all.
So does that makes sense?
So that's the way to think
about the eligibility.
All right.
So eligibility is
just capturing what we
expect the significance to be.
Yeah?
STUDENT: Is it the
quantity inside
the expected value brackets?
Or is it the expected value?
JOHN W. ROBERTS: It's this.
It's just this quantity.
It's not the expected value.
We want our update to be this
inside the expected value.
Then the expected value of
our update is the gradient.
So it's just the
quantity inside.
Right.
So I think I remember,
when I first learned this,
Russ was talking
about the eligibility.
And I had no idea
how to interpret it.
And if you still are
confused about it,
I can try to describe it in
more detail maybe with a picture
or something like
that if you'd like.
Do people think they have a good
idea of what the eligibility
means intuitively?
OK.
Great.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]?
JOHN W. ROBERTS: Pardon?
STUDENT: I know
eligibility [INAUDIBLE]??
JOHN W. ROBERTS: I'm going to
go through how you calculate it
right now.
Because E, you see,
is going to be this.
It's going to depend on
what our distribution is.
So I said, if we
parameterize our policy
by the means of a
bunch of Gaussians,
eligibility is going
to be one thing.
If you parameterize it as a
bunch of Bernoulli variables
or something like that,
it's going to be different.
So it depends on the kind of
distribution your policy uses.
All right.
So-- yeah?
STUDENT: If alpha isn't the
means of a bunch of Gaussians,
then what does
alpha plus z mean?
JOHN W. ROBERTS: z, alpha plus
z is always the action you take.
Sort of the-- we actually
had some notes on this.
If you think about it, let's
say that the way you represented
your controller, there are
some subtle differences here.
But yeah.
I think it's worth
going through.
So let's say I parameterize my
controller by three numbers.
Like gain on position,
gain on the speed,
and an interval term.
So this is a PID controller.
Right?
So this is something
that most of you I think
are probably familiar with.
So this is a very simple
parameterization of a policy.
Right?
Now, this how we control it.
Now the thing is that this is
sort of what the actions are.
So this would be, a beta
would be one of these.
An alpha-- and this terminology
isn't necessarily standard.
I think the alpha and z are.
My beta just came
up when I was trying
to make these notes so I could
have a simple term to write
down all these expressions.
But so this is your beta.
This is the thing you're
running your system under.
Your alpha is the
same size as that.
But what it is is
parameterization
for some distribution
of how you select these.
All right?
So in a Gaussian, I mean
I give you a simple one.
A Bernoulli
distribution, this could
be-- let's say KP was
either one or five,
then my alpha one could be the
probability of picking one.
And then the probability
of picking five
is one minus alpha one.
STUDENT: So in this case,
it's a specific evaluation
of your stochastic policy?
JOHN W. ROBERTS: This is
a specific evaluation.
This is the parameterization
that defines the distribution.
So once you tell me alpha, I
can tell you the probability
of getting any of these.
Right?
But when I run it, I have
these numbers in there.
So this is sort of like a
sample from a distribution.
And this is what I
actually get the cost of.
Yeah.
All right.
And so, if you look at this
minus this, that's the noise
we talk about in the
other interpretation.
STUDENT: And the
system you're trying
to solve is not, [INAUDIBLE]
how do you decide [INAUDIBLE]??
JOHN W. ROBERTS: Yeah.
So we're thinking about this.
This is another thing
I have a note on.
We're going about this
in the context of trials.
So you run the
system under a trial.
Right?
And then you evaluate the cost.
What if your system is
just running constantly?
Right.
Well, you can think about
a short period of time.
As a trial, you could
run it for a while.
You can look at discounted cost.
And then there's also the
average cost or average reward
formulation where you
can look at how long,
what reward you expect to get
running it off to infinity.
Like, what sort of reward rate.
I think about it right
now in the context of,
let's just say we can
do a trial of something.
And if you want to
worry about what
happens if this is
constantly running,
there are ways you
can still do a trial.
And then you can keep track
of an eligibility trace, which
is different than
this eligibility.
So that's a confusing thing.
What you can do is you
can be running constantly.
You can just sort of keep
iterating and take into account
the sort of coupling
or [INAUDIBLE]..
You can imagine
it's sort of like,
if I study for my test tonight,
I don't have a good night.
But I do well my test tomorrow.
So I was happy.
And so, it's sort of like,
then my action didn't give me
an immediate reward.
It gave me a reward later.
That's sort of
the delayed reward
problem, which is very common.
And there are ways of
dealing with this here where
you can still just look at
your accruing award right now.
And you can still
sort of give yourself
a reward for doing good
things in the past.
You can still handle that.
So I mean, that is
a good question.
And there's a number of
ways to deal with this.
But right now, just think
about executing a trial.
Right?
So then our E here--
again, to make it
look like what we want
it to look like, to make it--
well, that tells us
exactly what our E is.
So we can write
it as this vector.
d d alpha one of ln
probability of beta.
And this beta is
still this vector.
But the probability
of that is a scalar.
Right?
So this element of the
probability is just a scalar.
And that's our
entire thing here.
Right?
So then let's say again, this
is where the distribution you
choose comes into play.
Let's say that we
chose our distribution
to be a bunch of Gaussians.
All the different
parameters ID, the noise ID.
But we'll just think
about as an independent
with the same sigma.
So the probability
of getting a beta,
because they're
all independent, is
the product over all the
different parameters.
1 over square root of
2 pi sigma squared.
This is going to
cramp it if I do that.
So I think I have the opposite
problem of anyone else.
I write way too big.
Video people will be happy.
So let just me
squish it in here.
So probability of beta
is equal to product
over all my different
parameters with 1 over--
well, you know the
Gaussian distribution.
It's like this.
Right.
So if you give me a beta
and I have the alpha,
I can tell you the probability
of us picking that beta.
All right.
So our ln, the
natural log of this,
will then allow you to turn
this product into a sum.
And you'll get the sum
of over i equals 1 to n.
Now we can take this derivative.
This is a constant.
That won't show up.
And we'll just have
the derivative of--
yeah.
Yes.
So the derivative, now
we'll get rid of this.
This one is simple to do now.
It's just a product.
So the derivative of
ln P beta d alpha--
I did this again--
equals.
So beta i minus alpha
i over sigma squared.
Now if you remember how we
talked about it over there,
it ends up being [INAUDIBLE].
So here is our eligibility.
z over sigma squared.
Now what does that
mean our update is?
So hopefully, this
looks familiar.
My voice is struggling today.
I'm going to come in next
time talking like this.
It'll be great.
So this is our update.
Does this look familiar?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
Yeah.
Actually, let me-- yeah.
I guess so.
Does that look familiar?
Is this no, it does not
look at all familiar?
Or is this yes, it looks so
familiar, I don't waste my time
and embarrass myself
by saying it does?
It does.
Right?
It's the exact same update.
Now this one, we
don't have a baseline.
And we have sigma squared.
But that sigma squared
is just a scalar.
And we already said, baseline or
no baseline, whatever you want,
it doesn't affect it.
Right?
Now, is that true for this case?
It didn't affect the other one.
This one, it also does.
If you think about
your reward as--
if you think about your
reward as one everywhere,
then your derivative, let's see.
Where is this exactly?
OK.
All right.
So if this is constant, then
our derivative expected value
is zero.
That means that the expected
value delta alpha over here
has to be zero because it's
equal to that expected value.
That means the expected value
of our eligibility is zero.
Right?
So the expected value of the
eligibility is always zero.
So that means that
some constant in there
is not going to affect it.
Right?
When we do this expected value,
when we put in our baseline,
that's going to turn into zero.
Because the expected
value of E is zero.
The exact same thing
we had previously.
Right?
And you can see it's the case
for this specific example of z.
The expected value
of z is zero again.
So it's not going to affect
the direction of our update
and expectation.
So yes, you can do anything
like this with eligibilities.
You can still use a baseline.
Right?
So this is really the exact same
update that we already found.
All right.
So I think that's pretty cool.
Update that we
originally interpreted
as locally following
the gradient
is also following the
true gradient, not
some sort of local
but the true gradient
of the expected value of the
performance of that policy.
All right?
So if you have some really
ugly value function,
you throw this
distribution on top of it
and you move it around.
It's going to be
some, it's going
to follow in the direction
of true improvement there.
And a little test case.
I remember when I was trying
to think about interpreting
these things back when
we were originally
doing some of this analysis
on the signal to noise ratio,
if you think of little cusp, if
you have a value function that
has a little plateau on it, I
can write this on a fixed board
because it's not going to stay.
If you think you have
a value function that's
sitting around here, my drawing
isn't going to be too clear.
But here, we'll do it in 1D.
If you have a value
function like this,
you sit here and follow
the local true gradient.
It is very small.
The other one says that
you'll follow that gradient,
no matter how big it is.
So what it's sort of doing
when you have this Gaussian
is it smooths out the kinks and
stuff like this in your policy.
Right?
Because you think my
local analysis says,
OK, well, I'll just
get local enough
that these little kinks
in my value function
aren't a problem anymore.
But here, we say we
didn't say it was local.
We said it was global.
And so, it's following
this gradient,
even if we have ugly stuff
in our value function.
The reason is because
this distribution sort
of smooths that stuff out.
And now it's able to follow it.
So that gradient is
still well-defined.
It takes the stuff and
smooths it into something.
Does that makes sense?
I think it's just the big sort
of difference in interpretation
right here.
There's the one where
it's this local analysis
and follows the local true
gradient but only locally.
And then we have the other
one which follows even,
it doesn't require a small sigma
or anything like that anymore.
It'll follow the expected
value, the true gradient
of the expected
value of your reward.
And it's too big of
a mouthful for it
to be clear just by saying it.
But these are the two
different interpretations.
All right?
Good.
STUDENT: That function
is basically the policy.
JOHN W. ROBERTS: Oh yes,
I'll draw this better.
So here is sort of our alpha.
This is our reward.
Here we have our
[INAUDIBLE] function.
Our policy is taking actions
with this probability.
All right?
That's our policy.
So you can see that this-- even
though this has a kink in it,
as it moves that over a bit,
this is varying smoothly.
So even though this is a
little disconnected like that,
this is going to slide
over still smoothly.
Right?
So the gradient is always
going to be nicely well defined
and everything.
And this also goes
out to infinity.
So even if there's some
ugly thing way out there,
you're never going to
suddenly go and start seeing
stuff you never saw before.
You always sort of saw it.
Right?
So you'll be following the sort
of smooth one all the time.
And that's nice
because maybe you
won't be following when
you get really broad.
One interpretation says, well,
we're not in the linear regime
anymore.
So we're not following
that local true gradient.
This is sort of the
issue that brought it up.
Let's say this one says
it's the linear analysis.
And it says, OK.
If my sigma is
small enough, so I
sample close enough so it
looks approximately linear,
I'm going to follow
that gradient.
But instead, when
it breaks down,
you get this really
broad Gaussian.
So what does that mean?
Well, this one is still
following that gradient.
So that means that you're
seeing stuff all over.
And it's following that gradient
instead of this local one.
Right?
Now the problem is that, if
you follow that gradient,
the stochastic policy
isn't necessarily actually
the optimal one to follow.
When you're actually
running your policy
in the end, certain
systems you do.
But in many mechanical
systems, you don't actually
want these random actions.
Right?
There's the action that
actually does minimize cost.
And so, the sort of
local interpretation
has some value because
you don't necessarily
want to stick with the
stochastic policy forever.
That's why you sort
of reduce your sigma.
And you get tighter and
tighter and tighter.
And you follow the gradient
so it's more and more
biased to the right spot.
Because you can imagine, if
you have a value function
that's a global
min here, and then
say this is all extremely high.
And this goes down and
it's like a low plateau.
Now, if you have a
really broad Gaussian,
it may say, OK, well,
even though this
is the best spot to execute, I'm
going to slide way over here.
Because I have a sort
of lower expected cost.
Right?
That put you in the wrong spot.
If it was really tight,
then I'd say, OK.
Sit right here.
So do you see that
sort of distinction?
That this broad guy could push
you in the wrong direction
if it's really broad.
And you may not,
in the end, want
to execute a stochastic
policy for this exact reason.
Your stochastic
policy could have
a much higher expected
cost than a small sigma
stochastic policy.
Down to where, if
sigma is zero, that's
when you actually have
the minimum expected cost.
Yeah?
STUDENT: So when is this used?
It's used when you're
starting and you
don't know about systems?
JOHN W. ROBERTS: When
you don't have a model,
it's used in the same
context as the other one.
Are you saying stochastic
gradient descent as a whole?
Or--
STUDENT: I mean
stochastic policies.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
JOHN W. ROBERTS: It's
used for exploration.
Right?
Because our other one, where
we had this nominal policy
and we add a noise, that
doesn't look any different,
except from this sort of
interpretation, than this.
Right?
So--
STUDENT: So for the [INAUDIBLE]
and learning about systems--
JOHN W. ROBERTS: Yeah.
It's for exploration.
And you need it
to get more data.
Right?
Because if I run the
same policy all the time,
I don't know how
things are sensitive.
So my stochastic policy
gives me this information
to where I can learn.
Right?
So in the end many
times, yes, you'll
want a deterministic policy.
But for the development
of that policy,
you'll want to execute
all sorts of things
that could be suboptimal
to give you information.
And so, that is the
interpretation here.
It's for that learning.
And if your system
is evolving and stuff
like that, if it's
not constant in time,
you may want to always
run a stochastic policy.
Because you'll be able to
constantly learn, if that makes
sense.
So you may never
want to converge.
But I think it's-- yes?
STUDENT: How do you
obtain the parameters
of that stochastic policy
with that probability?
It's very sensitive
to sigma, right?
JOHN W. ROBERTS: How do I
get the parameters of what?
STUDENT: Of that distribution.
JOHN W. ROBERTS: Distribution?
Well, I mean that's
what I've set.
Right?
I said I'm going to act with
the probability described
by a certain distribution.
And I describe the
distribution here.
So I know these probabilities.
Because this, I set.
That's from my controller.
I designed that myself.
What I don't know is this,
this value function aspect.
STUDENT: So that it should
be based on intuition?
JOHN W. ROBERTS: No.
No.
This up here?
Oh, how do you decide
how broad this?
Intuition has something
to do with it.
Also, you can imagine sampling.
I think I mentioned
this on Tuesday.
You could sample.
You can imagine I
sample a few points
and I'd look at them here.
And they look straight to me.
And I'm like, OK.
Well, what if I sample bigger?
And I get these points.
And it looks relatively rough.
Then I go, OK.
Well, I want to be sampling
on probably the regime.
We're going to see this
roughness to some degree.
I don't want to be
stuck where it's
going to take me forever
to go anywhere because I'm
in the linear regime.
So you can do some
sampling and get
sort of the coarseness
of your value function.
And so, I mean that's
sort of before you run it,
you do some of those things.
And you figure out how
big these parameters are.
Because the alternative
would be you set it,
you see if it how it does,
and you fool around with them
all the time.
That's another way to do it.
But this way, you sort of
have a more direct process
for trying to be like, OK.
I want to be sampling
where I actually get
some interesting information.
And so, you want to be
sampling where you're probably
getting distributions
that cover linear--
it's fine if it's linear.
But you want to
actually sample to where
you're going to move around
to these different features.
You want to sort
of be able to get,
you want your updates when
you change your policy
to be on the scale, too.
Because it was really
small, it could take forever
to get down to the minimum.
Or if I was over here
and I had small sigma,
I may never sample over here.
So I'd never know
to move that way.
Right?
And so, if you have
a bigger sigma,
you might be to get
out of this local min.
So I sample over here
and see it's better.
And move in that direction.
Despite the fact that,
locally, it was bad.
So there's a number
of considerations.
But yeah, doing some
sampling and stuff
like that combined
with some intuition.
That's probably the
best I can give you as
to how to set these parameters.
I mean, that's a tricky thing.
That's something that's
nice about SNOPT.
There's no eta to set.
This one also has
a stigma to set.
So please, Russ emphasized
that I was to make all of you
understand this
stuff really well.
That's why I had two days.
And if you do it on your
project and you apply it
at the wrong system,
I'm going to be blamed.
[LAUGHTER]
Yeah.
So if you don't
have a model and you
don't have anything like
that, try that back prop first
if you can.
Try SNOPT first if
you can, I think.
If you can't, this
maybe won't do as--
this can solve the
problem, too, I guess.
But sort of appreciate
its limitations.
STUDENT: So with the stochastic
gradient and stochastic policy,
you also have to be
careful about how
you parameterize everything.
Right?
JOHN W. ROBERTS: Oh, very much.
STUDENT: Because, I mean, you
are taking the expectation
over these betas, which
are in fact instantiations
of your parameters.
JOHN W. ROBERTS: That
is a very good point.
STUDENT: Are you still having
that problem regardless
of which two you use?
JOHN W. ROBERTS: What
do you mean, which two?
Oh, whether you're using back
prop or this or something
like that?
STUDENT: Well, no.
Between the stochastic policy
and the stochastic gradient
descent.
JOHN W. ROBERTS: OK.
I really want to emphasize
something right now.
They're not different.
OK?
They're not, they're
the same thing.
All right?
You're correct that
your parameterization
is going to affect things.
Because you're going
to get to a minimum,
with respect to your
parameterization.
STUDENT: Right.
JOHN W. ROBERTS:
You're going to be
sampling over your parameters.
And so, the cost
function is going
to be a function
of your parameters.
So if you imagine, if you
have different parameters,
the cost function will
look completely different.
Does that makes sense?
If I were to parameterize with
an open loop tape or feedback
policy, how would
the value function
dependent on those parameters
be completely different?
So it's very important.
That's true.
It's over these
instantiated parameters.
So picking that
affects everything.
And picking a sensible
one can be a hard problem.
STUDENT: So there is
almost like another,
instead of just having
the sigma and the rate,
you also have to have
essentially these alphas
and [INAUDIBLE].
JOHN W. ROBERTS: You
have it for both, right?
STUDENT: Right.
Exactly.
It's like--
JOHN W. ROBERTS: Yeah.
STUDENT: It's almost you're
over-parameterizing everything
just so you can get an answer.
JOHN W. ROBERTS:
Well, I mean you
need to parameterize
your policy either way.
I mean, whether you choose to
parameterize it as an open loop
tape where you have 250
parameters or something
like that, you've still
chosen parameterization.
I mean, you still
picked a lot of them.
But you need to
represent it some way.
And so, I mean, whether you
do back prop or anything,
you're still going to have
that exact same problem.
I mean, you could do
back prop and make
it more efficient if you
had five parameters, too.
But it also can handle these
big open loop tapes and stuff
like that.
So there's less of a pressure
to find concise and sort
of compact representations.
But yeah.
But I want to emphasize that
these are different ways
of looking at it.
But update's the same.
The algorithm's the same.
The only difference
is, am I following
this local true gradient?
Am I following the
expected value of my cost?
So a toy example here to show
some of the practical issues
of some of these things.
And please, if you
have any more questions
about any of these things,
even if it seems tangential,
just let me know.
OK.
So here, we have what we just
talked about implemented.
You can see how simple
it is right here.
I'm doing a four loop instead
of that while converged.
But we have a loop through
some number of iterations.
I get my sigma and eta.
So this is so I can make
it dependent on the number
of iterations or
something like that.
So I can make them decrease.
I generate the noise according
to a Gaussian distribution
here.
I get my reward.
And the rest of
this is just sort
of plotting stuff and
everything like that.
And then here.
Here's my update.
And that's where
I've got my baseline.
Right?
So you can see that this is just
sort of that pseudocode right
over there.
There's nothing more.
All these functions
are just so that I
can switch between different
things really quickly.
But it's very easy to implement.
STUDENT: So you do the baseline.
And then the
equations, [INAUDIBLE]??
JOHN W. ROBERTS: Right.
I mean, this is
what pops out when
you look at that expectation.
But as we said, the
expected value of E is 0.
So if I have a constant in
there, my expected value
if I subtract off that
constant the same way,
it's not going to affect the
expected direction of my update
at all.
So these say you
don't need a baseline.
But a baseline has
performance benefits.
Right?
So that's sort of
another, if you
go these different
directions, this one says,
oh you don't need a baseline.
You can put it and it helps.
The other one's more
natural to think
about starting with a baseline.
Then you can say, oh well,
you actually don't need it.
So again, they both have
the same effect there.
Maybe I should have
been more clear.
But yeah.
So the problem that
we're looking at
is simply, we have a spline.
So I make a spline.
And then we're
trying to figure out
a curve that gets as close
to that spline as possible.
So it's really
just sort of we're
trying to fit a curve
to this random spline.
Right?
Now, obviously we don't need
to do anything fancy for this.
But it's very visual.
And so, I think it's
probably a good example here.
So we'll start.
The cost function we're
using is the square distance
between our sort of guessed
curve and the actual curve.
And try running it.
All right.
So on the left,
this is our cost.
Well, we have it formulated
as our reward here.
So it's negative.
And then over here, the blue
thing is the thing we want.
The red is our nominal.
And the green is our noise.
You see our noise
is pretty small.
I started it at L zero.
You can see it climbing here.
Right?
And it is getting better.
It's bouncing around a bit.
Yeah.
And so, this is actually
parameterized, this spline.
So it could be exactly
correct if we let it.
I mean, it's capable of
representing the curve exactly.
So the cost could be
zero, effectively.
Right?
I think actually,
if I have run it,
it gets stuck in a
local minimum, which
is a good cautionary tale.
Even if a problem
is simple like this,
you can still get
stuck in local minima.
So always be careful for that.
But see, it's actually
doing a reasonably good job.
Right?
Now you might be
like, oh well, it
has an ideal parameterization.
It's the minimum
number of parameters
you need to have a spline
that can represent it.
And this was the
same form of spline.
So that's a pretty
solid parameterization.
But we can try a different one.
This computer is
showing its age.
When I ran these tests on
my desktop, it went pfft.
And so, I had my
number of iterations,
like several thousand.
And then when I realized
it was going to do this,
I was like oh.
All right.
So here.
What parameterization
do you want?
Linear, tripolated,
nearest neighbor?
A polynomial?
All right.
OK.
[INAUDIBLE]
There we go.
Sorry about this.
It's not done.
Here we go.
Here, you see it's
capable of learning.
It has this is obviously
inferior parameterization.
It can't represent
the right answer.
But you can see it is
getting closer here.
It's not doing a bad job.
Right?
And the question of
what the optimum is here
is not going to look
just like the curve
because it has to
sort of balance
these competing things of
going over and going under.
So this is a good
example of where
your policy
parameterization doesn't
capture the true optimum.
And so, when this thing
converges to something,
it maybe is the best.
But it's only the
best with respect
to that way of
parameterizing a policy.
Right?
So if you guessed that nearest
neighbor is rich enough,
then you put it in here.
You're going to see
that it's not optimal.
Right?
That you've limited yourself.
And sometimes I mean, the
other one with the spline,
you put yourself in the
regime where you have
a very good parameterization.
You get very close
to the right answer.
Here, we have poor
parameterization.
And so, it's still
going to learn.
It's still going to converge.
But it's not going
to be as good.
So lin interp, we could
probably do better.
But here.
Now, we'll go back
to-- well, we'll
keep it in nearest
neighbor for now.
You can see lin interp.
All right.
Now I said previously that
this is partially nice
because it's robust to noise.
So here we're going
to look at, we're
going to add Gaussian noise with
a standard distribution of 20.
Let's see.
Here, it's not doing well.
I probably have to
reduce my sigma eta.
Let's see if we can get
back to where it started.
Yeah.
STUDENT: I think that's the
same thing as [INAUDIBLE]..
JOHN W. ROBERTS: You
multiply by sigma.
The variance is squared.
So this is not
doing a great job.
You see noise can break it.
If we start with a
bigger error though,
it's effectively
standard deviation.
Also maybe our eta
could have been too big.
Because we're getting
big measurements just
from this error.
So like a big eta, let's
try reducing our eta.
So it didn't get worse.
Learning is going to be
slow though, obviously.
Because it has such
a small signal.
But at least we prevented it
from doing that terrible thing.
That's because it was getting
these giant measurements
of error and updating
based on them.
But an expected value will still
go where you want it to go.
If you did a bunch of
updates, you'd be fine.
But that just gives
you everything out.
If we reduce that
down to, let's say,
learning will be really slow.
So let me turn off plotting.
I'm sorry about this.
I don't know what just happened.
OK.
So let's see how this does.
Ah, this is smoothed.
I ran a boxcar filter on it.
But it's not necessarily
learning quickly.
But with that noise,
it still learns.
Now if we're going
to be doing this,
we might as well kick
ourselves back to 20
and see if we can do anything.
Yeah.
So there, it's got enough
noise that it's sort of
been walking a bit much.
Maybe.
If you make your eta
smaller and stuff like that,
maybe make your
sigma bigger so it
gets a bigger signal when
it measures the change,
you might be able to be OK.
But I mean, it's still suffered
from these things definitely.
Now, another point here.
I talked about cost
functions a bit yesterday.
Here, we have one where
it's the square distance.
Let's say we--
I think I'm going to
give away whether it's
going to do better or worse
by having named it poor grad.
But this one, we're going
to get a reward of one
for each point that's within
of 0.05 of the desired point.
So if you're far away at zero
and if you're close enough,
it's one.
Right?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE].
JOHN W. ROBERTS: Right.
Where did my--
Oh.
So you see?
This is a much
shallower performance.
It still looks
like it's learning.
And it is.
Because I mean, even the bad
cost functions can learn.
But now I'm going
to show you what
that looks like when
you run it and actually
look at the plotting.
You see?
Now we can give it our--
we're still giving it
that linear interp.
Let's see if we give it
the better parameterization
and see how that does.
You can see it's not
learning nearly as quickly
as the other cost function did.
Right?
Let's get all our things back
to make eta a bit bigger.
See?
So here the only thing that
changed between our runs that
looked pretty nice and this run
right now is the cost function.
You see, it is over the course
of-- that's a 300 something,
it is getting up there-- but
if you remember the other one,
it's fitting a lot nicer.
Right?
And the thing is
that, if you look
at probably the cost
of the other one,
even using this cost
function, once you solve it,
the other one would
be lower as well.
Do you see what I mean?
The problem that,
if you solved it
with the other
one then evaluated
this cost function
on the solution,
that would be better than
this after some number
of parameters.
And it's because learning
based on this is hard.
Right?
You can see that
this is very coarse.
It's very easy just to
lose one or gain one
if you don't have good
gradient information.
And so, this is a bad cost
function for learning.
Right?
The same task, if this were the
task you really cared about,
formulating it with the other
cost function and solving it,
you actually probably do
better than solving with this
directly.
Right?
And that's because the
gradients in this one are poor.
It's not easy for it
to define the direction
it's supposed to move in.
And it's even worse.
I was talking before about how
you could be in regions where
you're getting zero cost
or zero reward for a while
or there's no gradient at all.
So if we start ourselves
with an error here,
it's not getting
any measurement.
You see?
Again, it's not changing
at all because it
can't measure anything.
So if we go to--
I said the way to solve that,
if you were stuck with it,
could be to use more
violent kind of sampling.
And there, you see we actually
are able to get some reward.
And it takes a while.
But you see that
there's more violent
sampling at least getting
out of that region
where we don't get information.
Right?
Still not the best.
But if you're stuck
with that problem,
that's one way to deal with it.
But you can see that, with the
other one where it doesn't have
any regions like that-- if
you go back to our nice grad--
sorry, I need to switch my eta.
Yeah.
Whoops.
We can go back to--
See how much nicer that is?
So there you go.
So here you can see
the parameterization
can affect it a lot.
The cost function
The eta and sigma
can affect it a lot.
There's a lot of concerns.
Right?
And that's why that should
make SNOPT and stuff more
appealing to you.
Because if you can complete
those gradients using back
prop, there's no
guesswork in that.
Right?
You give it to SNOPT,
there's no parameters to set.
I mean, I guess there's some
convergence criteria and stuff.
But you don't have
to play these games.
There's a lot of ways
to get this wrong.
Right?
So--
STUDENT: So the reason
that we introduce
the [INAUDIBLE] policy was a
way to explore [INAUDIBLE]??
JOHN W. ROBERTS: For here,
I mean they provide you
the exploration.
Yeah.
There's certain situations-- we
talk about gambling and stuff
like that-- where
stochasticity, if there's
an adversarial
kind of component,
stochasticity could be necessary
for optimality sometimes.
Right?
But in these kind of cases where
we have a dynamical system,
I don't see how stochasticity
in a deterministic system
could make you more
optimal than deterministic.
Right?
That's because the
system is deterministic
and not trying to guess
what you're doing and stuff.
So that's pretty nice
convergence right there.
And you see, if we
evaluated this solution
with our cost function of
one of the poor gradients,
I mean this is going
to be a lot nicer.
Right?
And that's even though we
wouldn't solve it explicitly.
It's just because the gradients
of this one are a lot nicer.
So you can solve it a lot nicer.
So remember that,
that cost functions--
even if it's not explicitly
what you maybe most care about--
for example, we care
about catching the perch.
Right?
But if you want to
catch the perch,
it could be that, by learning
with something with a distance
in it, maybe we'd learn
better and actually
end up catching
the perch more than
if our reward was just one
that could catch the perch.
Right?
So cost function design
can matter a lot.
Policy parameterization
matters a lot.
So hopefully you all feel
really comfortable using
stochastic gradient descent
now in the situations
where it's warranted.
STUDENT: Can you talk a
little bit about the baseline?
How do you get the baseline?
JOHN W. ROBERTS: Yeah.
My baseline here.
I think I have two limitations,
let's see something we can do.
So my baseline here, right now
I'm using a second evaluation.
Right?
We can do an average baseline.
I screwed something up.
Yeah.
I probably-- so
that's gone crazy.
But we'll try a smaller eta.
There.
So this is an average baseline.
See, it's still improving.
It's not doing as nice.
And it's also because we have
to turn down the eta and stuff.
I don't know that error was.
I'm not going to try
to debug it right now.
But you can see
it's still learning.
Now the real question is,
what if we have no baseline?
Right?
I made a really smart eta
there because now it's
not getting rid of anything.
Yeah.
You don't really have to
turn it down even more.
But that's a good example of why
a good baseline is so critical.
Right?
I mean, you can
see that all we did
was change how the baseline,
the average baseline
was working fine.
And it didn't cost us any more.
You have two extra evaluations
that we just got rid of.
We put in that.
And you see how much
it struggled there.
So I mean, if you just
do an average baseline,
you get it for free.
And it's still a huge
advantage over what
we're trying to do without
any baseline at all.
STUDENT: But we did--
I mean, it will
eventually work it out.
The baseline would
just be a lot slower?
JOHN W. ROBERTS: Yeah.
I mean, it should.
I mean, the thing is
that, in practice, it
can randomly walk around
and get stuck in places.
Like right here, you
see this is that.
It's a big run of
improvement there.
And it did better than
it originally did.
You see it's just
walking all around.
And so, yes.
I mean there's still this
bias towards improvement.
And it will work.
And if you were to calculate
a whole bunch of delta alphas
and then add them all
together, then you probably
wouldn't walk in the
wrong direction as often.
But here's the thing.
You have to remember that
it's sort of always moving
in the direction.
Right?
It's just it's moving
more or less, depending
on how good it is.
And so, yes.
This should still work.
But in practice, a good baseline
helps a lot, as you've seen.
So hopefully, all
those examples--
STUDENT: Is it also the case
that that baseline will not
hurt you?
JOHN W. ROBERTS: Well, how bad?
I mean, this could
be considered bad.
Right?
A zero baseline did that.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
STUDENT: Or can you actually
have a baseline that gives you
worse results than no baseline?
JOHN W. ROBERTS:
You probably could.
Because you could just
have it be a bigger error.
Right?
Just more in the
wrong direction.
STUDENT: Right.
JOHN W. ROBERTS: So Yeah.
But I mean that's
what I'm saying.
If you average over
the past several trials
like we did and then reduce
the rate of your learning
so that those averages are
relatively representative
and you don't move
too much on your own--
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE].
JOHN W. ROBERTS: Yeah.
But I'm saying yeah.
I mean, an average
baseline is free.
There's no extra
policy evaluations.
And it still helps a lot.
So an average
baseline makes sense.
And I mean, in something like
this where it's so cheap,
if you want those big
jumps and stuff like
that, the average baseline is
if the big jump can struggle.
Because the cost is so
different when you've updated.
Right?
So your average is going
to make a lot of sense.
But so they're sometimes
going to be better rather than
reducing your updates.
Like when we're really far
away from the right policy
and we have a long
way to move and we
could move in all sorts of
ways, that'd still be good.
The average baseline,
if we turn everything
down to the average baseline,
and it still works nicely,
that probably wouldn't be
as fast as doing two policy
evaluations and doing big jumps.
Right?
Where every time, you
just re-evaluate it.
STUDENT: It just resets it.
JOHN W. ROBERTS: And so, yeah.
To move it smoothly with
an average baseline,
we may need more than
twice as many iterations
as the one does when you
do an ideal baseline.
That's something that
I've seen in practices.
When you're doing
this big updates,
a real evaluation can be
fewer evaluations in the end.
So anything else or anything
else you'd like to see
run on the spline fitting
problem right here?
OK.
No one has any questions?
We're all good?
I'm going to tell Russ that you
understand stochastic gradient
descent perfectly.
And it's going to be extremely
useful in your research
in the problems to
which it is well suited.
All right.
Great.